The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last
time, we talked
about the responses of
auditory nerve fibers
and we talked about tonotopic
organization and frequency
tuning and response areas
of auditory nerve fibers.
So any questions about that?
OK.
So this time, today's
lecture was going to go on.
And the auditory
nerve, of course,
leads up into the brain.
So we're going to talk
about the auditory central
nervous system, starting with
the first nucleus in the CNS
for the auditory pathway,
which is the cochlear nucleus.
And this nucleus gets its name
because the auditory nerve
is sometimes called
the cochlear nerve.
Right?
It's coming from the cochlea.
And so this is the
cochlear nucleus.
So can anybody give
me a definition
of a nucleus in terms
of a central pathway?
Not a cell nucleus.
This is a nucleus in the brain.
Just a collection of neurons.
Right?
So a nucleus is a collection of
neurons in the central pathway.
A ganglion is a collection of
neurons out in the periphery.
So you have the spiral
ganglion in the cochlea,
being where the cell bodies
of the auditory nerve fibers--
it's called the ganglion there
because it's in the periphery.
And that nerve goes into
the central nervous system
and it ends on
neurons-- a collection
of neurons in the
cochlear nucleus.
In the part of the brain
called the cochlear nucleus.
We're going to talk in
the cochlear nucleus
about the various types
of cells that are there.
And instead of just having one
or two types of auditory nerve
fibers, as we had
in the periphery,
there's going to be a whole
bunch of types of cells.
And they have really
fanciful names
like octopus cells
and pyramidal cells.
So we'll talk about those.
When we go into the
cochlear nucleus and record
with microelectrodes,
we get single units.
And there's a way of classifying
those single units, which
was developed here
in the 1960s at MIT,
and it was one of the first
applications of computers
to the study of neuroscience.
Looking at the action potentials
as a function of time,
right after you turn
the sound stimulus on.
And by looking at
those patterns,
you can classify the
units into various types.
And now we know a
good correspondence
between the physiology
and the anatomy,
so we'll go over how we
establish that correspondence.
And because these are
these various types,
we really have one type of
auditory neurofiber coming in
from the periphery, and now
we have a bunch of types.
We're now going to
think of the system
as having multiple
parallel pathways
for the sense of hearing in
the central nervous system.
And perhaps one pathway helps
you with one aspect of hearing,
and another pathway helps
you with another aspect.
And maybe we'll end
up at the end of today
with a little bit
of discussion--
advanced discussion--
of implants.
So we're going to talk about
cochlear implants next week.
There is a kind of an implant
called the auditory brainstem
implant that's put in
the cochlear nucleus.
But here, things
are so complicated.
You have a variety of
cell and unit types,
each doing a different function.
You can imagine
how hard it would
be to wire up a prosthesis to
stimulate each one of those
correctly.
So just let's keep
in mind the challenge
of putting a prosthesis
into the cochlear nucleus,
which is required of people
who lack an auditory nerve.
They can't get a
prosthesis in the cochlea
because the message wouldn't
be sent to the brain.
They need to get a prosthesis
into the cochlear nucleus.
But it's very complicated here.
And maybe it's as
complicated processing
as you have in the retina.
Right?
In the retina, you have
the retinal ganglion cells
being very complicated.
Some have center
surround fields.
Right?
There's not just turning
on and turning off.
There's turning on,
there's inhibiting the
on, and so on and so forth.
So the cochlear nucleus
I think of a little bit
as like the retina equivalent
in the visual system.
OK, so let's look at the
auditory central nervous system
in terms of a block
diagram on the top
and in terms of what it looks
like when you cut sections
through the brain.
So here's the block diagram.
And we've been talking
about the cochlea here,
and the spiral ganglion
is where the cell
bodies of the auditory
nerve fibers are.
This would be the arrow of
the auditory nerve coming
from the spiral ganglion into
the CN, the cochlear nucleus.
And of course you have one
of those on the left side,
and another on the right side.
So this diagram is showing both
sides of the central pathway.
From the cochlear nucleus, the
neurons of the cochlear nucleus
send axons to a
variety of places.
One of them is in the region
of the brain called the pons.
And in the pons
there is a complex
called the superior
olivary complex.
And it's abbreviated SOC here.
So what's a complex?
Now, we've had a ganglion,
a nucleus, and a complex.
Well, as we'll see
in a couple of weeks
in the course, when
we talk about the SOC,
it has a whole bunch of nuclei
very closely spaced within it.
Maybe a dozen or so
different nuclei.
Each of which is a different
collection of cells.
So the whole thing is called
a superior olivary complex.
And superior olive?
What's that part of the name?
So has anybody heard
about the olive?
Or the inferior olive?
What's the olive?
We should talk about it.
Nothing?
Anybody?
Any ideas?
So it's involved in
the motor system.
And if you cut a
section of the brain--
it's not illustrated
here, but if you
look at a section of the brain
in transverse sections, which
are the kind of sections
that we have here--
you find a structure that's
kind of gotten wrinkled edges
and sort of has a central pit,
and it looks like an olive.
At least it did to the first
neuro-anatomists, maybe
who had their eye on the
clock, and were waiting
for the 5 o'clock dinner call.
They said, hey, that
looks like an olive.
And they probably didn't
have very good microscopes,
so they were looking at
things at very low power.
And what happened later
is somebody discovered
another complex over here that
was nearby but didn't look
anything like an olive,
but it was near the olive.
And it was a little bit
rostral in the brain,
and things that are rostral
are called superior.
So they called this
the superior olive,
and this has become known
as the inferior olive.
And after they got even
higher power magnification,
they could see this was
really a complex of nuclei,
so they called it the
superior olivary complex.
OK, so this is motor.
And this is auditory.
And they just happen to be
located near one another
in the brainstem, in the area of
the brainstem called the pons,
down here.
So these are sections
of the human brain.
So why do we cut sections?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: To look
at the anatomy?
PROFESSOR: To look
at the anatomy.
Right.
So a compound microscope
that we usually
use to look at the anatomy can't
look at a big hunk of tissue.
You have to cut sections.
And the thinner section you cut,
the better resolution you get.
Because you can bring a
very high-powered objective
and look at very
fine cellular detail.
So cutting sections is what
neuro-anatomists love to do.
An example thickness
of a section
might be 10 micrometers.
100 micrometers is a
very thick section.
So you can imagine
how many sections
you'd have to
chunk through to go
through the whole
human brainstem.
That's why it's nice to work
with small animals like mice.
They don't have
as many sections.
Right?
So, but these are sections
of the human brainstem.
And here, this word
says spiral ganglion,
so this is the auditory
nerve coming in.
And this is the
cochlear nucleus.
And I've heard it
described that by the time
the sense of hearing came
along, the brain was formed.
Primitive animals had the brain,
and all the other functions
like motor.
So there wasn't any
room in the middle.
So it was stuck on the outside.
The sense of hearing--
the cochlear nucleus,
at least, was put on
the outside of the brain
because there wasn't any
room for it in the inside.
Cochlear nucleus
structures tend to be
superficial in the brainstem.
This is the cochlear nucleus.
And these are the
axons crossing.
Because some of the
cochlear nucleus axons
cross from the left
side to the right side.
And the superior olivary complex
is deep within the brainstem.
But some of the
cochlear nucleus axons
don't go to the superior olive.
They bypass it
and go all the way
to the IC, the
inferior colliculus.
That's at the level
of the mid-brain.
So this is the
inferior colliculus.
So you've studied a
collicular structure before.
What was it?
Right?
In the first half
of this course.
The superior colliculus, right?
So why is it superior?
Is it better?
No.
It's just a little
rostral in the brain.
So if you cut
sections from caudal--
so this is the spinal cord
down, and your microtome's
chunking through the
medulla, and the pons,
and you get to the midbrain.
And then you cut through the
inferior colliculus, which
is right here, and then a
little bit more rostral,
you cut through the
superior colliculi,
which are right here.
And they tend to be
a little flatter.
These inferior colliculi
are more dome-like shaped.
So what does colliculus mean?
Anybody know French?
Who knows French?
Come on, somebody knows.
OK, who knows Latin?
OK, well, that's
the expected result.
Colliculus means a little hill.
And this lives up to its name.
These are little hills right
on the top of the brainstem.
The Inferior colliculi
are here, left and right,
and the superior
colliculi are here.
So what is the
superior colliculus--
what does the
superior colliculi do?
What happens when you stimulate
in the superior colliculus?
Your eyeballs move, right?
So the superior
colliculus is intimately
involved in saccadic
eye movements.
Right?
You guys must have
talked a lot about that
in the first part of the course.
And the inferior
colliculus, what does it do?
Well, I've heard people who
have spent their whole research
career studying the
inferior colliculus,
and they say, well, I
don't know what it does!
That's not an uncommon statement
in the sense of hearing.
So the inferior
colliculus certainly
is a meeting place for
lots of axons coming up
from the cochlear nuclei, from
the superior olivary complex.
It's a midbrain meeting center.
It's certainly involved
with many parts
of the sense of
hearing, but we don't
know exactly what role it plays.
Certainly not as simple
as it moves ears, OK?
Whereas the superior
colliculus moves eyes.
All right, coming up the
pathway even further,
the next level is the
thalamus, where you have,
for the auditory system,
the medial geniculate.
And what was the analog
in the visual pathway?
A lateral geniculate, right?
OK, so in the brain, medial is
toward the middle and lateral
is a little bit toward
the lateral part.
You don't have the lateral
geniculate in this section,
but it would be a
little bit lateral
to the medial geniculate.
And what does geniculate mean?
AUDIENCE: Knee.
PROFESSOR: Knee.
Right.
A genu is a knee.
And the lateral geniculate--
if you use your imagination
and if you were an
early neuro-anatomists
with a low-power lens
on your microscope,
it looked like a bent knee.
It's sort of bent.
The medial geniculate
is not that at all.
It doesn't look at
all like a knee.
But it's just medial to
the lateral geniculate,
so that's how it got its name.
OK, very good answer.
What is to genuflect?
AUDIENCE: To bend.
AUDIENCE: Kneel.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
To kneel down, bend your knees.
Ah, king!
Ruler!
All right.
And then finally we have
the auditory cortex, the AC,
in those boxes at the top.
And the auditory
cortical fields are
in the temporal cortex
on the sides of the head.
So I'm pointing to my
left temporal cortex
if I could go through my skull.
It's behind the temporal bone.
OK, where were the visual areas?
Back here.
This is called the
occipital cortex, right?
In a completely different
part of the cortex.
And in the primate--
of course, humans
are primates-- you have a big
temporal lobe of the brain.
And that's this lobe here.
And the auditory cortical
fields, for the most part,
are on the dorsal
surface of that.
And you have to go down
inside the temporal gyrus--
this big gyrus-- to
look and see them,
because they're
not on the surface
of the brain in the primate.
They're down inside
the temporal gyrus.
Well, how does this look
compared to the visual pathway?
Let's say this is
the retina here.
OK?
Where does the retina project?
That's a great exam question!
That's not a one
answer question, right?
In large parts of the LGM.
That's right.
Where else does it project?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I don't
know about that.
Certainly projects to the
superior colliculus, right?
Aren't the x and
y cells projecting
to the superior colliculus?
A few of the retinal
ganglion cells
project to the
superior colliculus.
You better ask Peter for sure.
Obviously, I don't know much
about the visual pathway.
But so how does that look here?
We have the cochlea, and
even the cochlear nucleus.
Does it project
to the geniculate?
No, not at all.
Between the periphery
and the thalamic level
for the auditory pathway, you
have the cochlear nucleus.
You have the superior
olivary complex.
And you have the
inferior colliculus.
And these structures are on the
main highway up to the cortex.
It's not as if the
main pathway bypasses
the inferior colliculus.
This little side arrow
is just a few axons.
The main pathway
is cochlear nucleus
to superior olivary complex.
And, to a certain extent,
cochlear nucleus to IC.
Superior olivary complex to IC.
And then to medial geniculate.
So it's a big difference
What about the
somatosensory system?
You have a dorsal root ganglia
in the somatosensory system,
and they project
actually all the way
to the somatosensory
regions of the thalamus.
So that's more like
the visual system.
There's something
different going on here
in the auditory system.
There's a whole bunch of
brainstem and midbrain nuclei
in the auditory
pathway that you don't
have represented in
these other systems.
So we're going to learn,
in about two weeks,
about the superior
olivary complex
and the inferior colliculus.
These extra brainstem
nuclei are very involved
in the process of
sound localization.
And that's because for
the auditory system
to figure out where a sound
is coming from, in best case
we use the two ears.
And we use cues like the
difference in time of arrival
of a sound at the two ears, and
the difference in sound level
at the two ears, to figure out
where a sound is coming from.
Certainly in the
azimuthal plane.
And in the visual system, and
in the somatosensory system,
the localization of where
the stimulus is coming from
is mapped right
at the periphery.
So you know that
a spot of light is
coming from over to
your right because it
hits your nasal retina
in your right eye,
and your temporal
retina in your left eye.
So that position
information is already
available in the periphery.
In the sense of hearing,
what does the periphery map?
It maps sound frequency, right?
So obviously, sound
frequency is a very important
characteristic.
It allows you to
identify the sound.
But it doesn't help you to tell
where the sound is coming from.
And if you're a mouse
running away from a cat,
and it's night time, and
you can't see the cat,
you need to know where the
cat sound is coming from.
Is it coming from your right,
or is it coming from your left?
And it takes a lot of
brainstem processing,
comparing the inputs
from the two sides,
to reconstruct where the
sound was coming from.
Especially if you're doing
it by intra-aural time
and intra-aural
level differences.
So all of this brain stem
processing-- or much of it--
is devoted to figuring out
where the sound is coming from.
It's figuring out the
location of the sound.
So we'll spend a good
week or more on that,
in a couple weeks in our course.
Because that's one
of the things you
can really sink your teeth
in, in the auditory system.
The thing it does
is to figure out
where the location of
the sound source is.
OK, now we're going to spend
the rest of the lecture
today on the cochlear nucleus.
The very first nucleus
in the auditory pathway.
And we're first going to
talk about basic things
like the anatomy of the cochlear
nucleus and its tonotopy.
So this is a drawing
of the cochlear nucleus
in the so-called sagittal plane.
We should all know what
the sagittal plane is.
Can anybody explain it to me?
Or can anybody explain?
Yeah?
Right like this.
So I like to think of it as the
zodiac character Sagittarius.
Right?
Who was Sagittarius?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: He was the what?
AUDIENCE: He was an archer.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
he was an archer.
Happened to have a
horse behind him.
Or for his behind.
So he shot the arrow, and
if he shot it effectively,
he'd hit me right in
the center of my head,
and my two halves of my
brain would fall apart.
And if you picked one
half up and looked at it,
you would a sagittal section.
OK?
Of my brain.
And the cochlear nucleus,
as we saw before,
is hanging off the
side of the brain.
But if that archer
shot-- instead of right
at the midline, shot
a little off-center,
and the cochlear
nucleus half fell away,
you'd get this sagittal section
of the cochlear nucleus.
And so the cochlea is down
here and the auditory nerve
is coming up into
the cochlear nucleus.
So what is up on this section?
Well, it's going
dorsal, going higher.
So here's your compass.
The cochlear nucleus is ventral.
The auditory nerve
climbs up dorsally
into the cochlear nucleus.
And that compass
gives you two clues
about the two big divisions
of the cochlear nucleus.
This biggest part of
the cochlear nucleus
is called the ventral
cochlear nucleus,
because it's down ventral.
The VCN is the ventral
cochlear nucleus.
And the other part is the DCN.
That's the dorsal
cochlear nucleus.
This is the part that
comes up dorsally.
And they look different.
If you look at the VCN, it looks
like sort of a homogeneous mass
of cells without a huge
amount of organization.
But as you can see by
these dash lines here,
the DCN has layers in it.
And people have pushed
the idea that the DCN
is like a mini-cerebellum.
| know, the cerebellum is
at the back of your brain.
Cerebellum means it's
a part of your brain
that deals with motor functions.
And has these beautiful layers.
Certain kinds of cells
are in each layer.
And there is an analogy between
the DCN and the cerebellum.
It certainly works as
far as the layers goes.
Some of the cell
types are the same.
You have lots of
little granule cells
in the cerebellum and the
dorsal cochlear nucleus.
You have pyramidal
cells in layer two.
The ventral cochlear nucleus, by
contrast, is very homogeneous.
Now this slide shows you,
in sagittal view, not only
the cochlear nucleus
and the subdivisions,
but it shows you some labeled
auditory nerve fibers coming
in, in the auditory nerve.
So we talked about
labeling before.
We talked about how you can
put a microelectrode filled
with neural tracer
in the auditory nerve
and get the tuning curve and
the characteristic frequency,
or CF, way down at the
tip of the tuning cure.
And then you can
inject a neural tracer.
And the last time, we talked
about labeling and tracing
the auditory nerve fibers in the
cochlea to the inner hair cell
that it contacted.
But you can just as easily
go the other direction.
Neural tracers fill
the entire neuron.
So these fibers were
labeled, and now we're
looking at their
central trajectory
into the central part
of the auditory nerve
and into the cochlear nucleus.
And it's pretty hard to read,
but if you could read them,
these arrows and the
numbers following them
indicate the
characteristic frequency
of each of four different
labeled auditory nerve fibers.
This one way down here has
a CF of 0.17 kilohertz.
This one is a CF of 2.7.
This is a CF of 10.3.
And the top one, I think,
is a CF of 36 kilohertz.
And you can easily see
a progression from low
CF's to mid CF's to high CF's.
So 36 kilohertz is way
beyond the upper limit
of human hearing, but in this
experimental animal, which
was a cat-- cats hear up to 50
kilohertz, at least an octave
above the upper
limit of our hearing.
And they have auditory
trainer fibers
that respond quite
well at 36 kilohertz.
So you can see that
there is a organization,
and this organization
could be called
a tonotopic organization--
for the projection
of the auditory nerve
onto the cochlear nucleus
and you can bet, than, that
if you were to explore around
here-- in the DCN that
we've been talking about--
if you were to record here with
an electrode that's sampled not
from the auditory nerve
fibers but from the cell
bodies of the cochlear nucleus.
And you can design
electrodes to record
from either fibers
and no neurons,
or neurons and no fibers.
If you were to use the latter,
and sample from the neurons
here, you would expect them
to respond to low frequencies.
Whereas if you were to
record from way up there,
you'd expect the neurons
to record and respond
to high frequencies.
And in fact, that's
what happens.
And these kinds of electrode
mappings of the cochlear
nucleus have been
done for many years.
These are data from the
'50s from the University
of Wisconsin.
So what's done here
is an electrode is
put through the cochlear nucleus
and each 100 micrometers or so,
it's stopped to record from,
in this case, cochlear nucleus
cells.
And their CF's are indicated
by the many numbers
here above the recording track.
And the CF, it looks
like, started at 0.5
and quickly went
up to 4 and went
higher and higher and higher.
And then went through a
region of the cochlear nucleus
where they didn't
sample any neurons.
And then they went through high
CF's and went back down to low
CF's.
OK?
Because they went into a part
of the ventral cochlear nucleus
here, where the
tonotopic mapping
was a little bit different.
And you can see how
an electrode might
record from a different
projection of frequencies,
if you had the angle right,
going from the dorsal cochlear
nucleus into the ventral
cochlear nucleus.
Because, as you can see, the
branches of the auditory nerve
fibers are quite
complicated here.
They all come up and
they do a bifurcation.
One part goes into
the VCN over here.
Another part goes through
And then finally
up into the DCN.
OK, so the tonotopy of
the cochlear nucleus
is quite complicated.
There isn't just
one tonotopic axis.
DCN has one, and in the PVCN
you can have at least one.
But this tonotopic organization
means the cochlear nucleus
neurons are also
tonotopically organized.
So we've transferred
tonotopy from the periphery
through the auditory nerve
and entered the brain
in the cochlear nucleus.
And if you go back to the
block diagram we just had,
cochlear nucleus projects onto
the superior olivary complex
nuclei in an organized fashion.
So you have such tonotopic
mappings in the SOC.
The SOC and cochlear
nucleus project
to the inferior colliculus, and
it's tonotopically organized.
Inferior colliculus
projects to the thalamus
and the medial geniculate,
they have beautiful tonotopy.
The thalamus projects
to the auditory cortex.
And you have at least a
half a dozen cortical fields
that have beautiful
tonotopy organization.
So this tonotopic organization
is a fundamental organizing
pathway for the auditory
central nervous system.
And it means,
basically, that you're
going to process certain
frequencies of sound over here
and other frequencies
of sound over here.
Keep the processing of
different frequencies separate.
And so why would
we want to do that?
Well, it's a matter
of debate, actually.
There's speculation on that.
But as we'll talk about
during sound localization,
you have different
frequency ranges
for the cues that are involved
in timing between the two ears
and level differences
between the two ears.
Some work best at
low frequencies,
and others work best
at high frequencies.
So maybe that is
the idea, that you
want to process those cues
for the location of sound
in different places
in the brain.
So tonotopic organization is
typical of almost all nuclei
in the auditory pathway.
So you could ask
the idea, are there
other mappings in
the other directions?
And it's not clear, in
general, whether there are.
Along the cochlear
nucleus in this dimension
there are different types
of cells that we'll talk to.
But we should
remember that there's
a third dimension coming in
and out of the screen here.
What dimension would that be?
That would be medial- lateral.
So lateral might
be close to you,
and medial would be far away.
So that actually
brings up the idea
that we're looking at
two-dimensional pictures
of three-dimensional structures.
And so I just brought in this
reconstruction, or this model,
of the cochlear nucleus
to remind us of that.
This is the cochlear
nucleus on the left side.
And I believe this
is from a cat.
This is many years old.
And you can see, in black,
some nice little cells here
that are lined up in the layers
of the dorsal cochlear nucleus.
So right here are the layers
And much of this is
up dorsally here,
so I should explain to
you what plane of section
we're looking at here.
This is the left
cochlear nucleus,
so it would be on my left side.
And now, these are
horizontal sections.
OK?
So for the compass for
horizontal sections,
dorsal is up.
Ventral is down.
Rostral is this way,
forward in the model.
And caudal is back.
Lateral is to the left.
And medial, where
the rest of the brain
is, on the right side, would
be over the right here.
The cochlea is ventral
to the cochlear nucleus.
And this is the auditory
nerve coming up.
And the colors are
meant to represent
the different CF's of
the auditory nerve.
So down here ventrally, we
have the orange, low CF's.
In the middle we
have green, which
is the middle CF's right here.
And very dorsally, which
would be way up in the top
of the screen in the
DCN, you have yellow,
so that's the high CF's.
And so that's the model.
So that's the DCN right here.
And down here would be the VCN.
And so this is a
model where there's
20 or 25 sections or so,
but many have been skipped.
In a typical cochlear
nucleus, if you
were to cut it 50
micrometers you
might have a couple
hundred sections.
So I'll just pass this around.
But there are two other
colors besides the three
that represented the
auditory nerve fibers.
I think-- what did I talk about?
Red, green, and yellow.
Right?
So there are two other colors.
There's orange, and
there's blue on there.
OK, so what's that?
Well, the auditory nerve
is not the only thing
that's providing input
to the cochlear nucleus.
Now you say, oh, this
guy made a mistake,
because on the block
diagram it showed
the only arrow going
into the cochlear nucleus
is from the spiral ganglion,
the auditory nerve.
All these other
arrows are coming out
of the cochlear nucleus.
So what are the
three other colors
that are not the auditory nerve?
Well, this is a diagram of the
so-called "ascending" auditory
system, from low to high.
Right?
The cochlea is the lowest.
The cochlear
nucleus is the next.
And then we went up-- chung,
chung, chung-- all way
to the auditory cortex.
Well, it turns out,
in all sensory systems
and all pathways there are
some direction and information
processing that goes
the opposite way.
Sometimes that's called the
descending auditory system.
So there's, for
example, information
that starts in the
cortex and goes down
to the medial geniculate.
And those other colors
in the cochlear nucleus
represent inputs coming into
the cochlear nucleus that
are coming from higher
centers and going down
to this lowest level of
the auditory pathway.
So those are so-called
"descending" inputs.
And those are not
very well explored.
Obviously, we know what
ascending input is doing.
It's telling the brain there's a
sound and it's processing that.
But why would the brain want
to send information down
to the lower levels?
Well, there are
lots of theories.
We'll talk about them toward
the end of our course.
But it has to do with the
brain controlling inputs coming
into it.
And there even inputs
from the brain going out
as far as the cochlea out
to the auditory periphery.
So those are what those other
colors are in the model.
Now we get to the
part of the lecture
where the cochlear nucleus
becomes very, very complicated.
The anatomical cell types.
And this is where Dorothy
might say to Toto,
"I don't think we're
in Kansas anymore."
OK?
Everything was really
simple in Kansas.
In the auditory nerve-- sorry
if somebody's from Kansas,
here-- but the auditory
nerve is very simple
and the cochlear nucleus
becomes infinitely more complex.
And so here is an example
of how complex it is.
This is the auditory
nerve coming in and making
its bifurcation to go into
the VCN and into the DCN.
And those drawings we
had before were just
sort of stick figures.
And they didn't show all
these nice little endings
onto this whole variety of
cochlear nucleus neurons here.
So how many cochlear
nucleus types are there?
There's about 10 of them.
So that brings me
to today's reading.
I guess I'm developing
this tradition here
of bringing a different
book every lecture
and reading from it.
So this won't take long.
This book is called The
Primary Acoustic Nuclei.
So that's another word
for the cochlear nuclei.
And it's by Raphael
Lorente De No,
who was a Spanish
neuro-anatomist at first,
and did a lot of work
on the cochlear nucleus.
And then during the
Spanish Civil War,
he said, well, I
better get out of here.
So he came to United States
and did a lot of work
on axonal conduction and
physiological measures.
And it says in the
introduction that he put away
his anatomical drawings
ever after maybe
publishing one or two papers.
And he had a whole
big file of them
in a manuscript, ready to
go, and he stuck it away
in a closet for about 30 years.
He dug it out, and
finally published this.
So a lot of this stuff was
done in the 1920s and '30s
and later published.
In fact, the copyright
date for this book is 1981.
And the inscription in
the front of the book
says December
20-something, 1980.
So this is important,
because this
is a book owned by Nelson
Yuan-Sheng Kiang, who
started this course,
904, with Dr. Schiller
back in the 1980s and '90s.
Nelson was very good friends
with the author, here,
and when the author
published the book
he promised Nelson to give
him the very first copy that
came off the printing press.
So this is the first
copy in the original run.
It's not only a
first edition, it's
the first of the first edition.
And the inscription here--
Nelson put December 1980--
is actually a year before--
a month before the copyright
date.
So this really,
really a special book.
So these pictures
here, as you can
see-- you can judge
this book by its cover.
These pictures are the
beautifully complex
incoming auditory
nerve fibers-- which
are drawn in orange here--
bifurcating and showing
the many, many types of endings
on the cochlear nucleus cells.
And that's summarized
by the reading here.
This is the very first
sentence of the book.
"Each neuron in the
ganglion of Corti"--
that's the spiral ganglion--
"gives rise to two nerve
fibers, which, according
to their destination,
are either called peripheral"--
those are the ones that are
contacting the hair cells
we talked about last time--
"or central"-- which we were
talking about right here.
"The peripheral fibers,
at times called dendrites,
penetrate the organ of Corti.
They form sensory
or afferent endings
in contact with the hair cells.
The central fibers, after a
relatively long trajectory
in the cochlear nerve, enter
the primary cochlear nuclei,
where they form elaborate
sets of endings."
OK, that's the reading for
today, and we pass it around.
You can enjoy the
pretty pictures.
So these are the
elaborate sets of endings
on the elaborate variety
of cochlear nucleus cells.
And one of this type
of elaborate endings
is called a large end bulb.
That's the very top one there.
And the other name
for an end bulb--
so, it's large end bulb--
it is the end ball of Held.
Because Held was the early
German neuro-anatomist
who first noticed
this huge ending.
So this ending is so
big that you can hardly
see the cochlear nucleus
cell that it envelops.
Here's another drawing
of the large end bulb,
and there's a scale bar.
The cochlear nucleus cell is
20 micrometers in diameter.
OK?
So you could say that's the
largest ending in the cochlear
nucleus.
Or you could say
that's the largest
ending in the auditory pathway.
Or you could say that's the
largest ending in the brain.
And you'd be right
with all those claims.
So this is a huge ending
from the auditory nerve fiber
onto the cochlear nucleus
cell, way at the tip.
And we can just go back
to the previous drawing.
These are stick figures
where most of the endings
are dropped off for the
purposes of clarity.
But way out of the tip of
the auditory nerve fiber
these end bolts of Held are so
big that you can see them even
with this really
low-magnification picture
of the auditory nerve fibers.
OK And they go onto a particular
type of cochlear nucleus
cell, called a spherical cell.
And in parentheses, that type
of cell is called a bushy cell.
Why are there two names?
Well, this is kind
of a long story,
but there are two main
techniques to look at--
or there were, in
the 1950s and '60s--
to look at cells in the brain.
And one of them was
to use a Nissl stain.
You can cut your
section of the brain,
cut your section of
cochlear nucleus,
put your Nissl
stain on it, and you
can see very beautiful
staining of all the neurons
in the cochlear nucleus.
Some of them look round.
The central nucleus.
And they were called spherical
cells because they're so nice
and round.
And this work was done by a
pioneering neuroscientist who
everybody before-- didn't draw
this very well-- everybody
before thought all the
cochlear nucleus cells just
look like one type.
They look about the same.
This neuroscientist, whose
name is Kirsten Osen,
was the first
person in the 1950s
to look at sections of
the cochlear nucleus
and say, oh, those actually
don't look exactly the same!
Some are spherical.
Some look like octopus.
Here's a cell Kirsten called
the octopus cell, because it
was sort of eccentric, and
these little appendages
coming off of it-- which were
the dendrites-- all came off
from one side, like the
tentacles of the octopus come
off from one side
of the octopus.
And this big nucleus,
right in the center, to her
looked like the
eye of the octopus.
Right?
Some of the cochlear nucleus
cells were multipolar.
Here's one called the giant
multipolar cell of the DCN.
And a pole just means that
something came off the cell,
and those are the dendrites.
OK?
The Nissl stain doesn't stay
in the dendrites very well.
If it did, the whole
cochlear nucleus
would be black because there
are dendrites everywhere.
But it stains the
cell body very nicely.
So what does the
Nissl stain stain?
It stains DNA, RNA,
and some protein.
Which are, of
course, found mostly
in the cell body of the cell.
So it gives you a good look
at the cell body of the cell.
Not a good look
at the dendrites,
because they don't have
as much DNA and RNA.
And hardly any look at the axon.
The axons are invisible.
But for classifying
cells, it's really great,
because you have every
single cell stained,
and you can look at them.
Here's a cell called
the globular cell.
And that is a little bit
like a spherical cell,
but it's more oblong.
Here are some other
multipolar cells.
Here's a cell called
the pyramidal cell.
So I should have said
that the Nissl designation
of these cells is given
non-parenthetically.
OK?
So you have, by Nissl, spherical
cells, multipolar cells--
here's another kind of
multipolar cell-- globular
cell, octopus cell,
and pyramidal cells.
So those are the cells I
would like you to know.
Those of the important
types of cells.
Let me write that down.
The view graph is
a little bit more--
it makes more distinctions than
I care to make for this class.
So you have spherical.
These are cells in
the cochlear nucleus.
Spherical cells.
You have multipolar cells.
You have globular.
You have octopus.
And you have pyramidal.
Right?
I mean, since scientists
are classifiers,
you have sub-types
of each of these.
OK, you could just
keep sub-typing
as much as you want to.
But these are the
main types that we
want to pay attention
to for our course.
And these are Nissl stained.
Now along comes another
person and wants
to make his mark on
science, and says,
I'm going to use a
different type of stain
and look at the cochlear
nucleus in a different way.
And his name was-- his
name is-- Kent Morest.
And he worked at Harvard
for quite a while,
and then went to the
University of Connecticut.
And so his stain that he used
was called the Golgi stain.
And many of the pictures
in the book I passed around
were Golgi stains of fibers.
He wanted to look at Golgi
stains of cochlear nucleus
cells and compare them
to the Nissl stain.
So what does the Golgi stain do?
Does anybody know?
Or who was Golgi?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Golgi
stains the whole cell,
but it doesn't stain all cells.
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
In fact, in the
ultimate case, you
can put your brain
in the Golgi solution
and come back a
couple months later
and you could just have one
neuron in the entire brain
stained.
But the good thing about
that is that the neuron cell
body, it's dendrites, and
a good portion of its axon
pick up the stain and
they stain it jet black.
So the Golgi stain
takes a spherical cell
and transforms it into something
that's really beautiful.
The cell body is
completely filled.
It's black.
I should be using black.
This is a black stain.
And you can see, coming
from the spherical cell, one
major dendrite.
It's a big one.
And it, very close
to the cell body,
ramifies into thousands
of little bitty dendrites.
Like this.
Where this scale might
be 20 micrometers.
And so the dendrite is sticking
very close to the cell body.
To Kent Morest, this
looked like-- he
must've been planting
stuff in his yard,
because this looked like a bush.
You go to the nursery,
and you pick up a bush.
Here's the top of the bush.
This is the trunk.
And this is the root ball
the nursery people bundle up
for you, or this is in a pot.
So this looked like a bush.
So he called it a bushy cell.
And so in parentheses
on the view graph
there are the designations
that are given to these cells
in the Golgi stain, which
is all in parentheses there.
It looks completely
different, because you're
staining different
parts of the cell.
So let's make our little chart.
Spherical cells in the
Golgi stain are called bush.
We'll put these in parentheses.
Bushy cells.
Multipolar cells are usually
called stellate because now,
instead of just the beginning
of the dendrite coming off,
you have long
expanses of dendrites
that go for 500
micrometers from the cell.
They can go across
the cochlear nucleus.
And they look like
beautiful, twinkling stars.
At least they did
to Kent Morest.
Globular cells look exactly like
spherical cells in the Golgi
stain, and they were
given the same name.
Bushy cells.
Octopus cells are so
clear, what they are,
they're given the same name.
Pyramidal cells are
sometimes called fusiform.
Fusiform means sort
of spindle-shaped.
They just look different
in the Golgi stain.
Now, this is sort of old stuff.
And so now, when somebody talks
about a certain type of cell
in the cochlear nucleus, they
use a hybrid terminology.
They'll say, "I was recording
from spherical bushy cells."
So they use both names.
Or, "I think I was recording
from globular bushy cells."
Or, "My study is on
multipolar stellate cells."
OK?
Or, "These cells in the DCN
are pyramidal fusiform cells."
So they use a hybrid
terminology and they
concatenate, if
you will, the two.
OK, so these are the
cell types, if you will.
Now let's go into the
cochlear nucleus and record,
with recording electrodes,
a sample not from fibers
but from cell bodies.
And see what we get.
I think that's what's next here.
Yes.
OK.
Where are these data from?
From Pfeiffer.
So Pfeiffer worked with Nelson
Kiang, who owns that book.
And they worked at MIT during
the 19-late-50s and 1960s.
And these were, again, some
of the first applications
of computers to neuroscience.
They said, well, what we
want to do from these cells
to classify them--
well, maybe they
used a whole bunch of different
schemes and all of them
didn't work out very
well, except this one.
They said, for this
one, what we're
going to look at for these
units in the cochlear nucleus,
is not the tuning curves,
not their responses to this
or that.
We're going to look,
very shortly after we
turn the tone burst
on-- the tone burst
is the stimulation--
we're going to look
at the timing of spikes.
And so these are in the order
of millisecond intervals.
In fact, some of the bins have
width less than a millisecond.
OK?
They want to look very precisely
at the time pattern of spikes
after you turn a sound on.
So tone burst.
What is a tone burst?
I've used that term.
So it's just-- I think we had,
earlier in the course, a tone
pip.
So a tone burst is just
sounds that to do this.
So it's a burst of tone.
Burst of a pure tone.
And it looks like the duration
here is 25 milliseconds.
OK.
And all these neurons
are tuned, so you
want to use your sound
frequency at the CF.
So within the tone,
versus the CF.
You want to get spikes
coming from the neurons.
So you want to be at CF.
You want to above threshold.
You turn your tone
burst on, and then you
have your computer
look at the spikes
and say when they occur in time.
OK, so this is pretty important.
So I have a pointer here.
So how did this experiment work?
Well, here's data from one, two,
three, four different cochlear
nucleus neurons.
And from each neuron there
are two types of displays.
This display on the top is
called a dot raster display.
And each little dot
signifies the time
of occurrence of a
spike, an impulse,
from the recorded neuron.
And on the Y-- down the
X-axis is the time axis.
So starting at zero is when
the tone burst went on.
Tone burst goes off at, looks
like, 40 milliseconds here.
And then there's an off
time when there's just
silence for the last
40 milliseconds.
And the important
thing about this
is that this column
here shows you
that there wasn't just
one tone burst presented,
but there were many.
And these experiments can use
600 or even 1,000 tone bursts.
Each time the
stimulus is turned on,
you give it a stimulus number.
So the very first tone burst
is stimulus number one.
And that's the first
dot raster here.
And the neuron fired a dozen
or so action potentials
at those times.
And then it stopped firing,
except for a little bit
of spontaneous activity.
Then tone burst number
two was presented.
And the neuron's dot
raster for number two
is the next line down.
Then you go through
your silent period,
and go back to the beginning.
Tone burst number
three was presented.
And you get this
pattern of spikes.
It's a little bit different.
Each one looks like it's
a little bit different.
Down here is tone
verse number 15.
OK?
And you get that dot
raster of spikes.
And then you go through your
hundreds of tone bursts.
And this might be tone burst
number 999 down at the bottom,
and you get that raster.
And you keep track
of all those dots.
And you have the computer
put them into bins here.
And this histogram
shows you the bins
where the number of action
potentials is along the Y-axis
now.
And the X-axis is
still displaying time.
And this horizontal line shows
you when the tone burst was on.
So this type of histogram, which
is compiled from many stimulus
presentations and
many dot rasters,
are sometimes called
the PST histograms.
And that stands for post-
or peristimulus time.
Obviously, it's
a time histogram.
Obviously, there's a stimulus.
Why is this a post?
Well, the terminology
started up when
you, instead of having a long
tone burst, have a click.
So that when the click goes
on, it goes off real quickly
and everything is
post- stimulus.
So it's really, in
this case, a peri--
around the stimulus--
time histogram.
Does everybody
explain-- Does everybody
know what I'm
talking about here?
About what this display is?
OK.
So you can think
of this PST, then,
as reflecting the
average firing rate
as a function of
time for the neuron.
And quickly, you're not turning
the tone on for many seconds.
It's within a few milliseconds.
Within the first 40
milliseconds of when
the tone burst is turned on.
And it's an average response.
And here's data from one unit.
Here's data from another unit.
Now, even in the
dot raster you don't
need to worry about
averaging here.
This type of firing
is fundamentally
different from the type of
firing we just talked about.
It looked like on
every single tone burst
there was a kind of a
different firing pattern.
Sort of random.
As if you took your
pepper shaker and just
spread out some salt
and pepper here.
There wasn't a real
organization to it.
Sure, there's a higher
firing during the tone burst,
after a little latency.
But over here, there's a
real nice pattern to it.
And it looks like in this unit,
which was called the Chopper
unit, even from the very
first stimulus number, it went
"pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop,
pop" if you slowed way down.
Same for the second.
Same for the 15th.
Same for the 999th.
This Chopper unit has a
very organized and precise
temporal pattern of firing.
When you do the averaging
and get the PST,
you can see this very nice
so-called chopping peaks
in the PST histogram
for this Chopper unit
as compared to this other unit.
Here is a unit where you can
also see, from the dot raster
display, that this unit
fired a spike and took
a substantial pause--
which gives it
a name, the Pauser unit--
before it started firing again.
And here is the PST histogram
from a so-called Pauser
unit, where the pause
is a substantial pause.
It's 10 milliseconds or so.
And finally, here's a unit
called an Onset unit, which
fires only one spike
at the onset of each
and every sound stimulus.
Each and every tone burst.
And obviously gets
its name, Onset unit.
Now, let's go back
to this first unit.
Why?
I glossed over the name.
Why is it called the
Primarylike unit?
Well, if you go and record from
primary auditory nerve fibers--
and where does that
terminology come from?
Well, in the auditory system
you have the hair cell,
you have the nerve
fiber-- so the nerve fiber
is the very first,
or primary neuron.
Then you go into
the cochlear nucleus
and you have the
secondary neuron.
So really, this is
a secondary neuron.
But the pattern,
the PST pattern,
that you get in some of these
cochlear nucleus neurons
looks just like primary
auditory nerve fibers.
Except they have a little
bit longer in latency.
So this one is called
Primarylike unit.
It's not a primary.
It's a secondary
neuron, but it's like.
Primarylike pattern.
OK.
So in the cochlear nucleus,
you have these different types
of firing patterns.
And let's make a list of them.
Maybe I'll make
the list over here.
So these are the unit types.
Primarylike.
Chopper.
Pauser.
And Onset.
Those are the four basic types.
Now, again, scientists
are classifiers,
so you-- if you read the
literature-- you will find
some units called
Primarylike with notch.
So those are Primarylike units,
but right after the first peak
they have a little notch.
Don't worry about that.
It's basically a
Primarylike unit.
Now, we have two interesting
classification schemes here.
One is how the unit
responds to sound.
One is how the neuron
looks in the microscope.
Can we make a correspondence
between the two?
Now, one possible
outcome could be,
"There is no correspondence."
Right?
Could be that spherical
cells can produce
any of those kind of
responses to sound.
Well, obviously, I wouldn't
be devoting a whole lecture
to this if that
were the outcome.
And in fact, the
cochlear nucleus
is a place where we can really
correlate anatomy of the cells
with their physiological
unit types.
And how is that done?
Well, there are
several different ways.
And this graph
shows you one way.
That is by going to different
parts of the cochlear nucleus.
Where the cell types are
not equally distributed,
you find that the unit types
are not equally distributed.
And this works very well for
certain areas of the cochlear
nucleus.
For example, this area
right here called OC.
That's the area called
the octopus cell area.
What's found there?
That's basically where you
have all the octopus cells.
They're found in a particular
part of the ventral cochlear
nucleus.
OK, let's go record there
with our electrodes.
And what kind of PST
pattern do you get there?
Well these are numbered types.
Where number one is Primarylike.
Number two is Chopper.
And these are sub-types of
Onset-- three, four, and five.
And number six is Pauser.
In the octopus cell area
you get Onset responses.
OK, so let's start
drawing some lines.
Octopus cells then
produce Onset patterns.
Now, that's true.
You can really sink
your hat on it.
How about going the other way?
Do you always get Onset response
from just octopus cells?
Or how about some of
these other types?
Well, going the other way, you
do have a few multipolar cells
that can produce the Onset type.
And how is that shown?
Well, octopus cells
are just there,
but you can get
some Onset responses
in various places in
the cochlear nucleus.
And I'll tell you
how this dashed arrow
was drawn in a minute.
So Onset units are not
only octopus cells.
Octopus cells are only
producing the Onset pattern.
That's the correct
way to say it.
Right here.
OK.
Now, elsewhere in
the cochlear nucleus,
the cells tend to be mixed up.
And you can't make very
good regional distinctions--
in spite of what's said here--
with one other exception.
In the dorsal
cochlear nucleus there
is a layer called the
fusiform cell layer.
And so it has the
pyramidal fusiform cells.
And there you get Pausers.
And that's pretty
much the only place--
well, not completely
the only place--
you get some deeper in the DCN.
But that's very good evidence
that the pyramidal cells
produce a Pauser
type of response.
You get no Pauser
responses anywhere
in the ventral cochlear nucleus.
Now, why am I messing around
with these messy data when,
to a certain extent, most of
the cochlear nucleus cells
are all mixed up together?
Well, you can
build up these data
from thousands of
recordings, and you
can look at hundreds
of cochlear nuclei.
You can assure yourself
this is the only place
that octopus cells are found.
You can record from
thousands of units
and not find too many
Onset responses elsewhere
in the cochlear nucleus.
So you have the strength
of numbers behind you
if you use this
type of approach.
We talked last time about
single unit labeling.
Why not apply that to the
cochlear nucleus neurons?
OK.
The way you do that is
you fill your electrode
with neural tracer.
You go in.
You record the CF
from the tuning curve.
Then you turn a tone on
and you get the unit type.
Is it a Primarylike
or is it a Chopper?
That's a very elegant way
to answer this question,
and it's been done, but it's
also extremely difficult.
For some reason, recording
from the cochlear nucleus
neurons with the type of
pipette [? electrode ?] that's
necessary to have your
neural tracer in it,
it's very difficult.
You get the recording and
then you go inside the cell
to inject it, and it tears
a big hole in the membrane.
And so the neuron
stops responding.
Have you lost the neuron?
Are you still in it?
You don't know.
OK, so that's very
difficult to do,
but it has been done on
this certain select number
of neurons.
And here's some data from
single unit labeling.
So here is from a study--
this is from a study
by Bill Rhode et al at the
University of Wisconsin,
in which he recorded
from cochlear
nucleus, Primarylike neurons.
That's clearly a
Primarylike PST.
He injected and
labeled the neuron
and recovered in the
ventral cochlear nucleus.
And there's what the
labeled neuron looks like.
There's a big cell with
one primary dendrite,
with lots of ramifications
close by the cell.
It's not as clear as the bushy
cell I drew on the board,
but clearly this
is a bushy cell,
because all the
dendrites are close by.
Now, I'm using the nomenclature
from the Golgi stain
because, clearly, that cell
is stained in its entirety.
The cell body is black.
The dendrites, every little
type of dendrite ramification
is filled black.
That big thread-like thing
going right underneath the title
labeled neuron is the axon.
You can trace the axon
wherever you want to.
This is Golgi-like
labeling that you
get from filling these
cells with neural tracer.
Clearly, that's a bushy cell.
And it had a
Primarylike pattern.
Now, if you look in
all the literature,
maybe you get about eight
or 10 filled bushy cells.
And people have spent many
years trying to do this.
You see papers published
with just a half a dozen
labeled neurons.
It's very difficult to do.
But clearly, that
Primarylike pattern
came from that bushy cell.
This Chopper pattern-- this
is a subtype of Chopper--
came from the stellate cell.
Clearly, rather than
one primary dendrite,
it had a half a dozen.
And the dendrites went forever.
Here's a neuron that
sent its dendrites
all across the cochlear nucleus.
Clearly a different type
of cell-- a stellate cell.
OK, so let's draw an arrow
there for those two neurons.
Bushy cells.
Spherical bushy cells.
We actually don't know
that it's spherical-- can
produce Primarylike.
Stellates can produce
Chopping patterns.
And these other
correlations-- octopus
cells correlated with Onset,
we already established.
And Pauser types correlated
with pyramidal fusiform cells,
we already established.
So we here have a nice
chart of correlations
between the anatomy
and the physiology.
And probably, this can be done
much better in cochlear nucleus
than any other
center in the brain.
Auditory system or non-auditory.
OK?
Now, you should be a
little bit skeptical of me,
as scientists, when I
give you these really
nice classification schemes.
So what is really the difference
between a globular bushy
cell and a spherical bushy cell?
You should be thinking,
"Can that guy really
make that distinction?"
OK, sure, some
things are spheres,
and some things are oblong.
But what about
something in between?
Are there intermediates in
this classification scheme?
So let me give you just an
arbitrary-- we classify people
by the color of
their hair, right?
There are blondes.
There black-haired people.
There are brown-haired people.
There are red-head.
But then you have a lot
of intermediates, right?
You have dirty blondes.
You have people who
have darkish brown hair,
not quite black,
but not quite brown.
What are you going to do
with all those intermediates?
What are you going
to do with people
who are losing their hair?
Problems with
classification schemes
are if you have a
lot of intermediates.
And then these
things break down.
Instead of being a
nice, firm category
they become really
squishy, with a lot
of intermediates
between the two.
It turns out, here, that
that's not a huge problem,
although it is
sometimes a problem.
The aficionados who
do this for a living
have metrics where
you can measure
the sphericity of a cell or
the oblateness of a cell.
You can measure things in
the physiological response.
Like if it's a pause longer
than two milliseconds,
it's a Pauser unit.
But if the pause is less
than two milliseconds,
then it's a notch,
or something else.
OK.
So it turns out that there
aren't very many intermediates
or things that are hard
to classify in these two
kinds of classification scheme,
which is very important.
Another important thing is what
do these classifications then
predict?
If you're recording
from a Primarylike unit,
and you say it's one of
these kinds of bushy cells,
what does it predict?
Well, one thing it predicts
is where the cells project to.
Now, that's given to you a
little bit on this diagram
here, by this category.
That says acoustic stria
for the efferent axon.
And so now we're
using terminology
that is centric to
the cochlear nucleus.
Efferent means going out
of the cochlear nucleus.
And there are three
major pathways
going out of the
cochlear nucleus.
The ventral,
intermediate, and dorsal.
And different types
of cells project
in one or another, but not all
three of these output pathways.
So knowing the type of cell,
knowing its response pattern,
I can predict where
the axon is going.
So the predictability of
the classification scheme,
if it predicts things
very well, means
that it's a good
classification scheme.
But when somebody gives you
a classification scheme,
you should always
be thinking, "Now,
is it a good
classification scheme?
Or it is just
something cooked up?"
Meaning, are there
lots of intermediates?
So speaking of
projections of the axons.
This is what I want
to end up with today.
Especially in terms
of the parallel
pathways that we talked
about at the beginning
of today's lecture.
So here's another
even different type
of diagram of the
cochlear nucleus.
This is the cochlear
nucleus on the left side.
This is a little
bit of the cochlear
nucleus on the right side.
And so we have a whole bunch
of the auditory pathway,
the superior olivary complex,
and the inferior colliculus
more in the center of the brain.
And now you can
get a sense of why
the superior olive
is really a complex.
Here are parts of it.
Lateral superior olive.
Medial superior olive.
Medial nucleus of
the trapezoid body.
Lateral nucleus of
And that's just part of the
superior olivary complex.
It's really a whole
bunch of different nuclei
all glommed together.
The point of this slide,
though, is the projections
of the cochlear nucleus
neurons, in terms
of where they send axons to.
So here are the spherical
bushy cells, right here.
That's its diagram here.
And this little
lending is supposed
to be the giant end bulb
of Held that they receive.
The spherical bushy cell on
the left cochlear nucleus
projects up here into the
left superior olivary complex.
And one of its most
important places to end up
is in the medial superior olive.
Part of the superior
olivary complex.
And it continues on and
goes across the midline
and also projects into the
right medial superior olive.
It's not diagrammed here, but
analogous spherical bushy cells
on the right side come
in and do the same thing.
The medial superior
olive is the place--
that we'll study in about a
week-- that receives input
from the two sides from
the spherical bushy cells.
And it compares the timing of
the inputs from the two sides.
It says, oh, if I heard
the sound on the left side
a little bit earlier,
then that sound source
was located to the
left side of my body.
But if the MSO gets input
from the right side first,
it's almost certainly the
case that the sound source
was located on the
right side of the body.
And it'd activate the right
ear and the right cochlear
nucleus and its axons first.
And by the time the sound leaked
around to the left ear-- it
a longer time to travel,
here-- and started
to activate the left pathway,
it was a lagging signal
and came into the MSO
a little bit later.
So the MSO, then,
receiving input
from these two spherical bushy
cells from the two cochlear
nuclei, does an
interesting comparison
and helps us localize the
sound using timing differences.
There's probably
a pathway in here
that begins with the
globular bushy cells,
where you use the differences
in level at the two ears
to localize sounds.
That's two out of maybe 10
different types of cells
that we really
know what they do.
So the other eight or
so-- the pyramidal cells,
the small cells, the octopus
cells, the stellate cells--
we have no idea what they do.
OK?
So all the rest of these
other parallel pathways,
the function are unknown.
We think they do something
in the sense of hearing,
but we're not sure what they do.
So there's a lot of
interesting information left
to be gleaned from these
parallel pathways coming out
of the cochlear nucleus.
OK?
So that's what I
want to end up with.
If there are any questions,
I'll take them now.
I also want to remind you
guys that next week, Monday
is a holiday, so there
won't be any class.
So the next time we meet is a
week from today, on Wednesday.
And in that lecture,
we're going to talk
about deafness and hearing
loss, and toward the end we'll
have our demonstrator come in
to demonstrate her cochlear
implants.
So that's an important
class, not to be missed.
OK, have a good mini-vacation.